[Musique]
on est à richmond en banlieue de
vancouver ici 60% la population est
d'origine chinoise
c'est une circonscription conservatrice
depuis 2008 et on est plus voir si les
tensions entre le canada et la chine si
ça pourrait avoir un impact sur le
baudet sino-canadien économie l'économie
il ya un mois touche bon clairement il
ya des électeurs qui ont d'autres
préoccupations que les relations
internationales
mais victor fang et vincent tu joues
tous deux originaires de chine
s'inquiète des rivalité grandissante
entre ottawa et pékin canada il aime les
valeurs promues par le parti
conservateur la répression du crime
l'accent mis sur la famille ou encore la
réduction des taxes mais la position du
chef andrew scheer face à pékin leur
déplaît j'exhorte justin trudeau à
reprendre avec force aux transgressions
de la chine le canada ne se laissera pas
marcher sur les pieds
depuis des mois le leader conservateur a
que justin trudeau d'être trop mou face
au gouvernement chinois
s'il est élu indochine au premier entre
autres de retirer les fonds canadiens la
banque asiatique d'investissement pour
les infrastructures a thing fils
trouillas je pense qu'ils jouent scheer
et naïf
il veut être dur face au gouvernement
chinois mais peut-on tourner le dos à un
marché de 1 milliard 400 millions de
personnes
mais dans la région de vancouver il ya
aussi tous ces immigrants qui viennent
n'ont pas de chine territoriales mais
donc qu'on ait eu le temps d'être très
critique face à pékin derrière moi en ce
moment il ya des étudiants qui sont en
train d'écrire déclare de soutien pour
des manifestants qui ont été emprisonnés
encore ces étudiants ont tous participé
à des manifestations à vancouver dans
les derniers mois pour appuyer les
revendications démocratiques de leurs
compatriotes hongkongais et quand justin
trudeau s'est prononcé sur la question
c'est une situation qui mérite plus de
d'écouté et de dialogue et moins de
réponse ferme et peut-être violente
il aurait voulu que canada dénonce de
manière plus claire le caractère
autoritaire du gouvernement chinois
j'aurais aimé que le gouvernement de
justin trudeau soit plus ferme
ces déclarations n'ont eu aucun impact
sur la position de pékin
l'électorat d'origine chinoise dans les
circonscriptions comme et richmond est
divisé par rapport à la chine il ya ceux
notamment ceux d'origine de chine qui
veulent une relation pragmatique qui
marche avec la chine qui souhaitent plus
d'engagement et puis de l'autre côté on
a d'autres électeurs notamment ceux
d'origine et hong kong qui souhaitent
une position plus forte par rapport à la
chine
[Musique]
dans huit semaines sans clé sino
canadien ont appuyé le parti
conservateur depuis plus dix ans mais
cette fois ci il se disait très
difficile à prévoir
car peu importe comment un parti se
positionne par rapport aux géants
chinois
il risque de s'aliéner une partie de
l'électorat ici le rend certains radio
canada avec chemin en banlieue